la confrontation rihad ankara continue
au delà de l'aspect juridique de cette
affaire il y a la volonté de la part de
la turquie de se présenter comme plus
responsable que l'arabie saoudite
et c'est en tout cas ce que nous
explique barah mikaïl professeur de
géopolitique à l'université st louis de
madrid
on voit bien que les saoudiens se
dédouane que même quand ils ont procédé
à des condamnations à la peine capitale
finalement ils ont annulé ces
condamnations en turquie c'est un procès
par contumace qui continuent à avoir
lieu aujourd'hui la turquie a annoncé
qu'elle était à la fin avec l'arrivée à
la fin de son enquête bon d'accord mais
je crois que le problème c'est qu'on va
continuer à être dans la confrontation
et que cette confrontation va continuer
tant que les relations saoudo turcs
seront basées non pas sur la volonté de
d'éclaircir les faits mais surtout sur
une rivalité de tipp régionale ou
internationale c'est à dire que
n'oublions pas que mon apens dans ce jeu
croient à tort à vouloir parler d'un
pouvoir ou d'un pôle sunnite qui
existerait au sein du monde arabe ou au
sein du monde musulman en général mme en
l'occurrence au sein du moyen-orient ben
non la turquie est un pays sunnite
l'arabie saoudite est aussi un pays
sunnite mais elle ne se voit absolument
pas marcher main dans la main et donc en
ce sens je crois qu'en bonne mesure
surtout de la part de la turquie
il est aussi une instrumentalisation de
la donne grâce aux objets aux fins de se
montrer comme étant un pays beaucoup
plus responsables tenaient leur avis au
lit